olha e aí galera que assiste meu canal
tudo bom com vocês Esse ano vocês gostam
muito dos vídeos de imitação Eu também
adoro esses vídeos eu boto porque eu
acho que para escutar música mesmo sou
dessas pessoas tudo que faz é uma
musiquinha Ah não sei o que ele vou
treinar musiquinha Play Então hoje eu
resolvi reunir todas as imitações que eu
já fiz nesse canal aqui em um só vídeo
não adianta me pedir para imitar as
pessoas em qualquer lugar gente aqui a
gente se prepara faz uma preparação
vocal toma chá gargareja bota aqui no
áudio do microfone que é feito já
especialmente para isso Ó esse é o áudio
ó é o áudio de cantor então se você
achar alguma dessas imitações muito
parecida clique em gostei eu sei que
você não vai gostar de todos não tem
como que vai aparecer todos nem tem como
você tem que estar de muito coração
aberto pra achar tudo parecido mas a
gente tenta né mas se algum você falar
[ __ ] isso aqui é [ __ ] você já clica em
gostei já clique em compartilhar manda
pra mim
disponível do primeiro link da descrição
do vídeo Hein Quem quiser comprar o Hype
para ficar hypado vídeo de imitação não
ganha dinheiro nenhum vai tudo para os
cantores originais da música então se
você quiser me ajudar assiste o clipe
que está no link da descrição do vídeo
barulho de chuva barulho de chuva para
dormir tipo assim para ajudar o Liu eu
não sei inglês então alguns eu vou
tentar alguns eu vou inventar Espero que
você se divirta lá essa menina é o bolo
bom dia pro alto quem tá enlouquecendo
não puro talento descendo chama a
mãozinha pro alto quem tá enlouquecendo
[Música]
gosta de bailar não vai não eu vou
gostar demais
pois é essa vida é muito louca é eu já
fui saber como é não vários modão que
testa a nossa fé vai se tiver mandado
voltar de ré
eu não posso gravar um vídeo de imitação
Toda vez que você quer gravar Cala a
boca morri você morre em todos os
universos possíveis morem Acho que cada
jogador é só sua própria modo de fazer
jogar futebol e cada humorista vocês só
forma de Zé comédia Ah você pô e agora a
coisa mais importante que já me
aconteceu nesse momento em toda minha
vida
um paredão Perfeito completo perfeito é
teoria da relatividade
no momento
e quem é matar você
[Música]
eu vou rifar meu coração
vou fazer leilão vou vender ela quer
enganar mais
e te dizer
[Música]
eu não posso negar
não faz isso comigo não
lembro de você qual eu tô no plantão
madrugada É Solidão
para me acompanhar
[Música]
Ai meu Deus que calor bota aí o ar
condicionado Vale mulher se algum Você
tá gostando clique em gostei
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Ô Janaína vem com o boga na linguiça
vários homens bomba bomba bomba bomba lá
vários homem bomba bomba bomba bomba
aqui vários homem bomba bomba bomba
bomba bomba
[Música]
e vai para todas as meninas de verdade
vem na coreografia vai só de sacanagem
só na funerária
[Música]
eu acho que tá de boa isso daí Porque o
povo brasileiro
vai come comida da vovó
Angélica é eu quero um pouco de biscoito
[Música]
a de brilhar mais uma vez
quero ter olhos para ver
é maldade que desaparecer
[Música]
[Aplausos]
joelhos sobre
[Música]
a sua
Ave Maria
mãe de Deus Jesus
[Música]
Boa noite apenas você vai ter
fim
eu bobo fui eu
[Música]
o destino deve estar nos olhando com
aquela cara de
quem e eu tentei
te juntar vocês dois
e o destino deve estar
[Música]
Não quero compromisso nem tão pouco me
apegar
[Música]
eu tenho visto na vontade de chorar
tenho medo de acordar de madrugada e uma
luz sem apagar da refletir ela para mim
sei que está tão Curio
vem louca pra me perguntar
quem está no seu lugar
quem roubou o meu coração
e mudou o meu coração
se chama
solidão
[Música]
Então é isso aí o vídeo de hoje foi esse
se você gostou de algum Não esquece de
clicar em gostei não rapaz é que ele
ficou muito parecido eu quero que você
comente aqui embaixo Qual é o que tá
faltando eu imitar o hino você tá
faltando metal pessoa até agora Você
enrolou enrolou e não me tou falando Eu
espero que você tenha gostado eu fiz deu
muito trabalho acho que eu tô rouco viu
comecei bonzinhos aquecimento a noite
todinha aí quando chega aqui fica desse
jeito mas eu espero que você tenha
gostado estou muito feliz e não esquece
de escutar barulho de chuva no Spotify
tamo junto valeu é nós